le plus de talent tu es le plus célèbre
des couturier yves saint laurent
pourrait annoncer demain son départ les
rumeurs vont bon train celui qui a
révolutionné la mode d'auteur du smoking
ou du tailleur pantalon a déjà depuis
plusieurs années sa place de son vivant
à new york au musée de la mode
estelle cola patrick descheemaecker
voici près de 25 ans que l'on n'en finit
pas d'annoncer son départ départ qui
entraînerait la fermeture définitive de
la maison de l'avenue marceau
désigné par christian dior comme son
successeur le petit prince de la mode a
connu tous les succès j'ai mis quarante
ans à me trouver et parfois jeu sur son
corps dit yves saint laurent il est
capable de faire la plus belle robe du
soir de d'habiller une reine et en même
temps d'aller prendre aux marins son
caban csn un voyou son blouson aux
militaires sans son trench coat et puis
les adapter à la femme depuis près d'un
demi-siècle le mâle allure fragile
mobilise les devants de la scène en
habillant les femmes en hommes en leur
donnant cette allure androgyne
il est devenu le couturier le plus
célèbre du monde comme en témoigne son
ancien collaborateur
on m'a toujours demandé ce que est ce
qu'il ya un secret ou es ce que vous
avez trouvé le secret de la maison et
j'ai dit oui mais c'est pas une formule
c'est un laboratoire pour moi le secret
de de la maison de saint laurent c'est
le fait qu'ils avaient beaucoup
d'émotion dans les abbés fest régler le
sort des quelque 150 employés d'ateliers
un comité d'entreprise extraordinaire
est convoqué demain à 9 heures demain
peut-être la fin d'un bras de fer entre
d'un côté le couturier son partenaire
pierre bergé et de l'autre leurs
actionnaires françois pinault
il est peut-être un petit peu fatiguée
un petit peu dégoûté de tout ce qui se
passe dans la mode aujourd'hui je vous
savez le futur cet effet pour
accompagner un art de vivre cet art de
vivre a disparu seule certitude ce soir
l'homme qui a révolutionné la garde-robe
féminine devra demain midi surmonter sa
lésion des timidités pour donner une
conférence de presse et mettre fin aux
rumeurs